everybody welcome back to Pike sex
campaign mode now today it's time to
look at Western roundup and the
description is and it's an old Wild West
town that's seen better days if you can
get past the heat there's lots of space
for a large amusement park so apparently
there's probably some bit of a weather
challenge to this park so we might need
to sell a lot of drinks or provide a lot
of shade that's something to look into
it's a little bit more difficult than
Victoria Lake it seems since we have to
get 500 guests which is the highest goal
so far as well as a Happiness rating of
75 percent and that's the only part
which concerns me maybe a little bit
since the park tickets yoursel that kind
of goal at some point anyway so that's
not too difficult but then the happiness
rating I haven't actually looked at it
so far and I assume that my park so far
have done alright on this but I'm not
entirely sure so yeah let's just get
into it and try to see what the theming
so far is like this is one of the
scenarios which I also didn't make this
was made by Josh so I'm gonna try my
best to sort of emulate the look of the
western town which we have so far but
really it's very much just to give you a
start and a bit of an idea of what you
can do with the theme but aside from
that it's not really giving any
challenges with the terrain or the
scenery it's pretty much an empty
sandbox
so I think that's a good start I think I
can work with this the rides are pretty
limited though so I think I'm gonna want
to research thrill rides get a little
bit more of that I'm not too concerned
about the calm rides because they don't
earn as much as much money and get as
many guests in as the other rides I
believe so that'll be something to focus
on I just saw a lot of roller coasters
so that's definitely something to
experiment with it would be really nice
to build something like a themed mine
train at some point when I get the money
and maybe a small junior coaster again
although a Walt Mouse is also very often
a western themed ride as well so we'll
see what I can do with that in any case
let's get into the time-lapse all right
now Joshua did an excellent job on the
existing scenery so I'm just gonna try
and do my best to fit the stuff that I
build in with the similar sort of
theme although I didn't want to add an
extra bunch of benches and litter bins
for practical purposes also pay
attention to this queue line which I'm
placing right now because I'm gonna
forget to hook this up to any part for
the next 10 minutes
so yeah the I if you're cringing at this
then I will be too don't worry we're in
this together I will hook that thing up
eventually the time will come once I
finally get the park running I also got
a comment about my queues on the last
video by King rct3 and actually it was
the video before that but I didn't have
time to address it in the last video so
here it goes anyway he was talking about
how I don't make my queues obvious
enough like a queue entrance should be
something that you make quite a bold
statement in the lands in the landscape
so to speak a really obvious and big
sort of thing to attract guests into and
I tended to hide my queues sort of in
the bank of the ride and not make the
entrance very visible so that's
something I should definitely work on
but for now I think for these kinds of
simple flat rides I'm just taking the
cues and the entrance the exits and the
entrance next to each other and just
alongside the ride and I think it should
be more or less fine that way in this
case I decided to put a simple cover
over the queue and the rocks at the back
of the ride a little bit inspired by the
one ride in slot hardened which people
who know the park in the Netherlands
probably know what I'm talking about
it's the one with the rocks that look
like meatballs with cowboy hats so I
think it's a nice way to themed a flat
right like this especially if you have
that Western theme just put some rocks
to the back of it make it seem a bit of
a canyon like setting and that can
pretty much work for a cheap and easy
way to theme a ride now over here I
decided to move into the main streets
and it's a bit peculiar I suppose that
you don't get into the Main Street right
away after you enter the park but I
guess it sort of more or less works the
the path just does a few different
things before you move into the real
Main Street and this is where all of the
frontier style houses are gonna be and I
have to be completely honest this is the
theme which I've rarely ever done
I think throughout all of my roller
coaster tycoon 3 and planet coaster and
park attacks videos I've never done a
western-themed ride or Park or any
section of a park even so I'm a little
bit inexperienced when it comes to this
stuff to be very honest so I looked up
just a bunch of reference images and
went from there I think the one thing
that does make my life a little bit
easier is that Western tends to be a
really simple theme anyway because the
obviously the the settlers didn't have
all of the resources so their houses
tended to be quite simple and they're
quite boxy and made out of simple
materials as well and I think that
reflects in a theme-park sense as well
very often you'll see that small local
parks have western themed areas or are
completely western themed as in the case
of silicon and because well because of
the the characteristics of a Western
theme they're super cheap and easy to
build for Pikes as well so I think
there's an over-representation of
western themed areas in small family
parks just because it's a very cheap
theme to build and because of that
there's a lot of reference for it so
that's nice at least I know there's the
the examples for Hanan but there's lots
of different parks as well that even if
they aren't exactly entirely western
themed they always have this one little
area and then there's a good place to
put a saloon as well and sell some
american fast food or something like
that but maybe that's also a bit more of
a european theme I'm sure you don't
really find this sort of stuff as much
in America unless you're looking at
actual authentic theme parks like
Dollywood and Silver Dollar City in any
case I decided to go for the
stereotypical Western theme for these
buildings so they're just wooden boxes
with slightly more detailed and fancy
facades at the front and different kinds
of colors because I do want to bring a
little bit of color into the scenario
I'm very much afraid that with the color
for the terraforming and the paths and
the even the rockwork and the buildings
so far everything is gonna be too Brown
so I do want to avoid a complete
monotony when it comes to the color so a
few colored Western buildings I think
should help with that as well now over
here is the third flat ride actually
connected the cue for this one so I'm
very proud of myself and I decided to
just put a roof over the Q as well as a
path which leads to a future area of the
park and not entirely sure what I'm
gonna do with that yet I'm gonna be
building an extra flat right there in a
minutes but that's not entirely what I
am planning to end up doing with that in
the future but we'll have to see I think
I mostly tend to sort of plan my parks
in my head based on where the coasters
are gonna be and how the coasters are
gonna be laid out because you can always
sort of wiggle some flat rides here and
there but it's when you build the
coasters that you really need to sort of
think about your layouts a little bit
more to address some of the questions in
the comments as well I had some
questions on the last video also on how
I just come up with in general theme
park layouts and how I pretty much do it
just on the fly and it's a bit of a
difficult question for me to answer
because there's not so much a method to
it I think there's just a lot of tricks
that I've learned throughout the years I
suppose of playing rollercoaster tycoon
and playing Park effects and similar
games like that
I mean I've played these kinds of games
for way too much right now like I've got
a few hundred hours in park attacks
which isn't too much but I'm sure if you
count my hours in the different
rollercoaster tycoon games we're
counting many thousands of hours at this
point so I think a lot of it is just
down to that sort of experience but
there's definitely some things to keep
in mind I think one of the easiest
tricks is to have extra wide paths and
mix up the path textures a little bit in
Park tech specifically I always like to
put fences in the middle of the paths so
that it splits up the path into
different parts where you can put more
lights and more benches and more
everything and then a lot of it is also
just down to putting some furniture into
the
no matter how nice-looking your layout
might be of your parts are completely
empty it's not going to end up looking
very charming or inviting so over here
for example I'm putting the string
lights over the path
lots of benches lots of lamps wherever I
can some planters and litter bins and
sometimes even some clutter as well it
depends on the theme what came work but
in this scenario I'm just adding some
random barrels and crates everywhere
like I'm some kind of video game
designer but yeah stuff like that I
think also works out quite nicely and
it's also different kind of party like
path layouts I think for different kinds
of areas so over here for instance we
have a main street so it's three tiles
wide with some planters in the middle
that works for that kind of case but
outside of a Main Street I would
normally want to avoid something like
that I think to tile wide paths are just
about enough in parked x1 tiles a little
bit too small you can use that for a
little paths somewhere or small
shortcuts but for the bulk of guests I
think to tile wide and then filling it
up with all kinds of objects is good
enough so yeah there's that short talk
now over here is where I decided to
build the Gravitron with a bit more of a
fitting color scheme pretty rustic in
pretty warm colors like everything else
in the park so far and trying to emulate
the sort of surrounding scenery that the
carousel had just in a different way
here with these supports and it's a
pretty western style of doing the
pillars at the wooden pillars I think as
well where you have all of these cross
beams these diagonal beams supporting
them I don't know it just reminds me of
a Western kind of look so there's that
and over here I decided to finish the
main street I actually forgot to put an
extra path between those two planters so
the space between them is one tile
instead of two tiles but uh I think it
works alright so here's the the coaster
that I decided to build I thought about
building a wooden coaster and actually
tried that for a little
but I quickly threw away that idea
because it turned way too expensive and
I didn't quite get the ratings that I
wanted because this coaster it's it's
going to be a themed for sure and it's
not purely here for any kind of well
gameplay reason but I needed a
rollercoaster really badly I didn't have
anything with high ratings and I didn't
have any ride which attracts a lot of
guests so so far it's been really quiet
in the park and the wild mouse coaster
is great for being super compact easy to
build being very cheap and giving you
pretty high stats also for how small it
is it's a pretty easy ride to get medium
or even a higher intensity on so this is
what I decided to build I should also
say it really fits the Western theme as
well I think these things also tend to
be very common in these parks with
Western themes as some examples I think
that come up in my head is a Hansa Park
in Germany
I know it's lahar and not actually Bobby
Allen's in Belgium which also has a sort
of Western theme in that area has one of
these as well and there are loads of
examples like that they are really great
for real-life theme parks for the exact
same reasons that I just mentioned as
well so yeah all together I think it's a
pretty good fit for the park I had to
make the queue extremely long although
that said from a realism standpoint it's
actually just about what I want Mouse
coaster needs so it's not too bad and it
also allows for some interaction between
the queue and the coaster itself and for
some more scenery so I actually kind of
like having the queue down there
it was mostly inspired by the queue of
honza parks wild mouse which has a
similar sort of section where it goes
between the layouts of the coaster
itself and it's always nice because it
gives you some time when you're standing
in the queue to look at the coaster go
around and basically fear for your life
as you're about to ride one of the most
uncomfortable coasters ever but hey
that's what about most coasters are all
about
oh and there's one thing that I forgot
to mention this is a wild mouse type
coaster but I decided to swap out the
regular cars for the minecarts cars
which pretty much perfectly fits the
Western theme as well so that's another
part of this ride which I think fits the
scenario very much but then again that's
not really so much my choice but
definitely on the guys from parks taking
themselves I don't know if it was Joshua
who did this or if the research in this
map was added later on by the park that
guys themselves I think it was actually
but you can definitely tell that all the
rights that we're getting in this
scenario are at least loosely
western-themed so we've got the mine
train and the mine carts on the wild
mouse and the wooden coaster a junior
coaster because you always have one of
those things but overall it's a it's a
pretty dramatic bunch of rides I think
so yeah there's that I think it also has
some interesting interaction with the
station building because you always have
that one part where it sort of loops
back over the station and I thought it'd
be nice to put a little tower in the
middle of this station and have the top
part of the tank go through that and
then another part of the track is moving
over that sort of wooden porch that
extends on the back of the station
building
so yeah altogether it's a pretty nice
and easy way to get some interaction
between the coaster the paths and the
scenery now that'll be it for this Walt
Mouse coaster
so even though the surrounding area
isn't very much finished yet I suggest
that we go into a quick real-time
section to see how the park itself is
doing management wise all right now the
park is definitely not doing too shabby
in fact it's doing way too well I'm
already making five hundred dollars a
month which is up make that six hundred
dollars I suppose but most of it is
actually coming from this little right
over here which is making some really
good money here there's one not so much
actually the carousel is doing pretty
average as those things do I at last
this is this is where I hooked up the
queue so there's that spike
so the jumper is gonna do all right
eventually and this ride is
doing pretty fine is one actually forgot
to open this one for a quite a while so
even though I was not quite in the right
mindset to get this park to run all
right I think this coaster is
single-handedly saving me so I think it
was a great idea to get that loan
because I am building this thing and
everything else I build around here on a
loan but it was definitely a good idea
to do that because that's what I needed
to actually run a profits here now the
idea is to build some kind of
centrepiece building over here a weenie
if you will maybe another building over
here I'm not quite sure what's and then
expand into different territories
elsewhere so possibly I could build a
wooden coaster along here but I'm not
quite sure if I want to I'm thinking
more something along the lines of a
family coaster since this is sort of the
entrance area and there's a lots of
gentle ish rides over here and yeah I
could maybe put a wooden coaster
somewhere in this part of the park I'm
not entirely sure yet I'll just come up
with some things during the time lapse
but yeah there isn't too much to talk
about no vandals or any other such
issues I'm doing quite alright when it
comes to the decoration although looking
at it this way I I will need to repair
some stuff so maybe get a little bit
more stuff get some janitors here and
there and maybe an extra mechanic to fix
some of the vandals that I do get but
overall I seem to be doing more or less
fine so there's not really much to work
to worry about except maybe negative
news about theme parks I suppose but
yeah overall we're doing pretty well I
also think the weather isn't really much
of a challenge at all like I expected
there doesn't seem to be any problems
with weather it just means that I don't
get any rain which is actually perfect
so maybe I do get a little bit of rain
but it's a little bit less challenging
since there's less rain and there's less
the things to worry about when it comes
to getting rain coverage and getting
rides that people will want to ride when
it's raining so yeah doing all good
let's go into the time-lapse again and
build some stuff
all right so I know that I said earlier
that I would put some kind of weenie or
something interesting at the end of the
main street but in the end I didn't
really think anything would fit there
I think these towns are typically all
just quite cheap and simple buildings so
I'm just gonna stick to the same style
as the rest of the Main Street finish it
off with some very similar buildings
although what I did realize and this
probably refers to a point I've talked
about earlier in one of my videos I like
to sort of have an idea of a certain
color scheme to use throughout a park
but I do like to mix it up as much as I
can as well so what you're probably see
me do a lot even though everything's
going really fast in the time-lapse is
using the pipette tool to copy a color
from a previous building but then just
slightly shifting the color of it which
i think is just interesting because it
means you can have sort of similar
colors throughout the different
buildings that mean that they all fit
together quite well but at the same time
the colors are ever so slightly
different so you don't get the feeling
that all of them are default colors
because we have such an amazing freedom
in what kind of colors we choose in park
texts I feel like it would be a waste to
not make use of that
so these buildings again are just gonna
be pretty simple facades with different
wooden boards and really not too much
detail and this is something where I
really have to hold myself back as well
because I really like detailing
buildings a lot but in this case I'm
just gonna have to choose every detail
then I place very carefully instead of
just ending adding endless details
everywhere I think I also forgot to put
some doors and windows on the ground
floor which is a bit annoying because I
now put some roofs over there so I can't
exactly tell where I've built stuff and
where I haven't which is just the thing
because I like to keep laying an
isometric mode I know a lot of people
like to play the game in 3d but I do
prefer it in isometric to get that sort
of classic feeling of a theme park same
but yeah I might have to return to that
at some other points because I'm pretty
sure the walls of the ground floor are
pretty much just the walls at the moment
but yeah that shouldn't be too much of
an issue and then the yellow building on
the corner there is a bit of an end to
the Main Street I suppose because I
really do want to keep things simple I
was thinking about some kind of
centerpiece here like a gala or
something but nothing really worked out
so I just ended up putting a tree over
there speaking of which I do realize
that I have a lot of trees in this Park
especially considering the setting is
pretty much a desert but I would just
like to stay within that sort of
suspense of disbelief that this is a
theme park after all and they're
probably gonna have some trees even if
it is very high maintenance and you
wouldn't really see it in the natural
surrounding it's just something that
makes the park look a little bit nicer
and even though I'm gonna use them
sparingly to keep the idea of the theme
intact I do have some trees here in
there it would look very dead and
desolate without all of those trees but
I'm also sticking to ones that I feel
like they would do all right in this
very arid climate so I don't wanna go
too far there so it's all just gonna
stick to pine trees and and one of the
things that I also really like is that
you can subtly change the color of trees
as well so I'm trying to desaturate all
of the trees and make them a little bit
more gray and dark ish then there are
standard colors which is always a nice
trick as well I think you can give trees
really ridiculous colors to have some
kind of effects like an alien planet or
make them white in a snowy biome stuff
like that is always interesting so yeah
there's that now over here I'm moving
into another junior coaster and these
are already becoming a bit of a staple
of almost every single Park that I'm
making and I'm almost getting used to
building these things there's always
very similar sort of strategy to it just
trying to create all these different
alyssa's and a very sort of mild layouts
that sort of weaves in and out of itself
and that's really all there is to it so
I'm trying to get as much variation with
these things as I can but they are
starting to look alike a little bit but
god they just work really well and
realistically they are present in so
many different theme
that I want to try and get them in as
many of the scenarios as I can as
possible as well see how there's that
that's why I'm building this thing again
and it's always a bit of a puzzle to get
back to the station over here but I
think in the end this layout with the
two curves sort of stacked on top of
each other is pretty much well perfect I
wouldn't really be able to improve too
much but I think
and it's personally my favorite junior
coaster layouts so far we'll see what I
get to in the future but I think it
works quite alright and I just turn it
into a blueprint really quickly there
just to move it around which I would
also give to anybody as a tip it's
really easy to just blueprint around
really quickly if you just want to move
it or something like that or have a half
unfinished right that you want to move
to a different location before you
finish it which is something that I
ended up doing later in this episode but
I'm not gonna spoil anything yet it's
just a quick tip and then for the
station I'm just sticking to this style
that always more or less put into the
park by Joshua and have these log
pillars that hold up the roof which i
think is really nice as well I feel like
the effect which they give you is of
slightly overhanging roofs which is nice
because park attack doesn't have any
overhanging moves I know there's some
kind of mod and I'm not I'm not quite
sure what it's called but it's something
anarchy I think that allows you to put
grid items on off grid positions but in
the case of vanilla Park attacked the
roofs and walls etc are all just
placeable on four grid tiles so I think
you have to get creative to get these
sort of overhanging roof looks like with
pillars that are just within the borders
of the grid like these log pillars
alright so then for the scenery I'm
following the weird roller coaster
tycoon strategy of changing the color of
the ground underneath the track and
adding some foliage here and there I
don't know what the thing is we're
changing the ground underneath the track
it's just just something that looks
pretty decent it's it's easy to do but
I'm gonna go back and change that a
little bit later for now though I
decided to build the second coaster
and I wasn't originally planning to
build such a high-tech and modern
coaster like the RMC monorail which you
see here but I left my research running
for a little bit too long and I ended up
getting all of the coasters of the
scenario and I saw this thing and I just
thought to myself wow I need to build
that I haven't built one of these things
in a while and they're one of my
favorite coaster types also real quick
what I'm doing here is building
different heights of pieces just so I
can get a transition into that dive loop
which you normally can't do so you can
see that it sort of moves upward a
little bit Wow it's also banking to go
upside down which is super cool so you
know using that sort of autocomplete
function of the game which has been
added recently you can really make all
kinds of new transitions which is really
nice but yeah I think it's a build a
monorail coaster just because I really
like these things and I think it's sort
of fits the theme the monorail coasters
which we have so far in the world are
Wonder Woman less oh of truth I think
it's called and real blazer and they're
both in the US and they both have a sort
of theme which goes all right with the
theme of this park I think so that's
sort of what my mind
well thinks about when I think about
these coasters so I thought you know why
not put it in the Western Park as well
it's gonna be the one very thrilling
coaster of the park and I think it works
quite well to put it out here in the
back together with the drop tower so
yeah there's the layout I decided to
have that one section which sort of
sticks out and there's an over-banked
turn over there
because I want to fill that in with a
flat right later to have some nice
interaction between the coaster and a
flat right somewhere near it as well and
then for the rest of the layouts
basically I'm trying to base this as
much on the existing monorail coasters
without completely stealing their
layouts so you have that very signature
drop where it goes down into a little
curve on the top of the lift hill and
then it goes up again before it moves
into a very steep drop into a dive loop
and after that it's really compact it
just kind of sticks together on a very
small space and
there's lots of inverting elements so
yeah very much a standard typical Raptor
layout if you could call it that just in
case this is because I always sort of
assume that people know about these
things but you might not this coaster is
based on the real-life coaster by Rocky
Mountain construction usually people
just call it RMC and it's called the
Raptor coaster which is why I've been
calling it the Raptor even though in
game it's pretty much just the monorail
coaster but yeah these things are real
now which is really interesting and it's
one of the most recent coaster types
really 2018 is the first year when the
these things were actually built in a
build life and so far it's just the the
one person for a car version so it's a
really small coaster with the tiny track
and really small cars but there's also a
two-person per car version called the
t-rex which hasn't been built yet but we
might get one of those things in the
future would be really cool it's more or
less a bigger version of this coaster so
yeah I'm also building a transfer track
over here just for that little bit of
immersion I suppose since we will be
having two trains on this coaster and I
thought hey why not build a transfer
track as well I'm keeping all of these
things very simple though I think I've
got some criticism on the one that I
built in the first episode and honestly
I don't really care too much about the
transfer tracks here I just want to keep
them somewhat believable but I'm not
gonna go too much into detail on them
because they're not actually gonna have
a function or anything like that really
now for the scenery on this coaster I'm
pretty much doing the same thing kind of
changing the ground a little bit in a
short time I'm also adding some rock
work and some foliage and some very tall
fences normally I would put tall fences
around paths whenever the coaster track
is really close to the paths because you
just don't want people to climb over the
fences and hurt themselves because this
thing happens actually quite a bit in
real life theme parks and a lot of the
accidents that do occur in the
parks I think are often if people
breaking the rules anyway now here's the
flat ride that I wanted to put in this
space I had to turn on a bit more
research while I was working on the
coaster because I didn't have any flat
right that actually fit the space but
now we do and it's the magic carpet ride
which is a bit much of a bit more of a
Middle Eastern ride I suppose but it
fits and it says slightly there's a
theme to ride anyway so I figured might
as well put that in there and then
behind that I'm putting up the the logs
as a sort of backdrop for the flat ride
and I really like making those fences
with the pillars I'm not quite sure who
ever came up with that idea it
definitely wasn't me but it's a really
fun way to make your own sort of custom
fences and you can always add these
little variations in the heights of the
logs to make sure that they actually
look somewhat natural and realistic and
it's it's really nice to sort of have
some more flexible offensives and
scenery around the park so it's
definitely something that I'll be using
in some of my future hikes as well
whenever this sort of log fence can work
out regarding the theme now that's
basically it for the time lapse so let's
check out the park real quick you know I
think the park is doing a little bit too
well at this point I'm almost reaching
the guest goal I have a lot of money
down there and I'm actually earning a
lot of money every month as well so I'm
not quite sure if it's really too
challenging anymore but that said I
think if I build one more coaster a
really big coaster to attract a lot of
guests and a bunch of flat rides that
should be just about enough to reach the
guest goal but also enough to actually
finish the park of in a nice way because
that's essentially what I'm trying to do
here as well and so far I think this is
actually one of my favorite parks of the
scenario so far it's it's turning out
pretty well and very much like a sort of
realistic organic theme park layouts
which honestly surprised me a little bit
as well because I really never planned
out these things I just sort of do what
I feel like in the spur of the moment
and this park turned out surprisingly
decent see I'm pretty happy with that
and the only space where I can release
expand is over here I'm gonna well
basically end the park at the monorail
coaster over there
so really the space here is what I have
left at this point so I'm thinking of
building a wooden coaster over there
although that said it would also be
interesting to build a mine train so I'm
not quite sure what I want to try a mine
train would be something really
interesting and something new to try but
I'd also like to try another GCI wooden
coaster because I sort of got an idea of
how to do them with the last scenario
but because the land over here is
completely empty and flats it would be a
much more interesting space to try and
make my best out of it so I'll see what
I'm actually gonna do but either one of
those ideas and then combining that with
a few flat rides into its own little
area I think should work and then the
park should be more or less finished
although that said the goal in terms of
the guest counts is pretty high I've now
realised I thought it was pretty low in
some of the earlier scenarios like the
scenario so far are really quite easy
but this this park really demands you to
build quite a lot of flat rides and
coasters until you're able to reach the
goal so a little bit more of a challenge
right there maybe no maybe the park is
not much harder but it definitely
definitely takes more time to finish
then the other scenario is in any case
let's start building Oh God so I decided
to go for the challenge and build a mine
train which I've never actually tried
before in this game and which I knew
would be much more time-consuming and
part of me is also regretting that
decision because this is already
becoming a really long episode and my
original ambitions was to kind of make
the episodes at least something like 30
minutes or less and that's not really
happening but I wanted to try my hand at
a my train because it just fits the
theme of the park too much and I really
wanted to try building one of these so
yeah we're going for this now the mine
train I think is very much inspired by
the four coma mine trains
honestly I don't really exactly know
what the standard mind trained in these
kinds of games are because in real life
you've sort of got the the two industry
leaders being four coma and arrow arrow
mind trains being more of the older ones
and all of them having the wooden planks
between the tracks and then the takoma
ones are the the sort of modern ones
like Big Thunder Mountain in Disneyland
Paris and the Seven Dwarfs mines rain
etc so I think it's of the latter and
because of that I decided to model it a
bit like of a common mind train as well
my biggest inspiration was the mine
train in wallaby belgium which has a
very nice compact layout which doesn't
use as much rock work as the very
heavily themed mine trains like Big
Thunder Mountain do but it still has the
same general theme and that's I think
the most fitting for the scenario
because I don't think the the park that
I'm making in this scenario could quite
you know afford a big thunder mountain
honestly barely any Park in the world
would but something like this seems
pretty feasible so I'm going for a very
minimalistic theming with to lift Hills
next together which is sort of a comb on
my train thing I suppose although I
think at some point other mind trains
started doing it too anyway a basic set
up in terms of a layout like that and
then the station next to it and a little
bit of interaction there we've got the
lake with the coaster having a sort of
bridge over the lake and then the queue
is positioned in such a sense that
you'll be very close to that's and for
that most of the queue line you'll be
looking at you know either the station
itself or this sort of Vista with the
coaster
in the foreground above the lake and
then this sort of rock work in the
background so I think as a general
landscape it works pretty well it's also
fun elements to add to the coaster
because honestly I wouldn't know what
kind of scenery to really add to the
coaster outside of rocks and general
mind
detail elements so having a bridge like
this is a nice way of having some kind
of you know memorable beats in the
coaster layout if you
where you're going over a bridge and
it's not really doing anything for
little moments you can just sort of look
around as you're in the coaster look at
the scenery take it in before you get
smashed into that helix and I say
smashed because these things are there
for koma coasters after all so they're
not really the most smooth things so
here's the rockwork a very basic I
didn't want to put rock work around the
entire track the majority is still being
held up by supports so yeah it's not
really a big thunder mountain edge
coaster but still it sets the theme
pretty well I think and it creates a
sort of mini landscape for the coaster
to go through I also kind of want to say
and maybe this is a bit more off topic
but I wanted to talk about it anyway my
favorite personal favorite my train
coaster which is also a vakama my train
is the Colorado adventure in Fantasia
land it used to be known as Michael
Jackson's Colorado Adventure or
something like that I'm not quite sure
because Michael Jackson opened it and
the park was really proud of it but they
I think they more or less got rid of
that mantra I only hear some people talk
about it in that sense right now but
yeah it's absolutely my favorite mine
train because even though it's not as
well themed as other mine trains are
it's a little bit of a mess have to be
honest there are some points where you
just go through a warehouse and it
interacts with the other rides of the
park but not always in the best way but
the layout is absolutely insane it's
pretty intense for a mine train it's
supposedly a family coaster but it hits
some pretty intense G's at some points
and what's also really fun about that
coaster is that some of the interns are
extremely over-banked so when you think
about a mind train coaster you tend to
think about these sort of kid-friendly
very smooth gentle rides but this thing
actually kind of throws you around and
in some of those over-banked curves you
actually banks too much like almost 90
degrees and you just smash into the
person next to you either that or you
you
get smashed into yourself by whoever's
next to you so I don't know it's always
a bit of an adventure and that's why I
really like the ride even though I'm
usually more of a scenery kind of person
I like the the combination of the
setting and the pretty rough ride that
it gives
so maybe this was inspired by that a
little bit but I don't think this
coaster is really Colorado adventure
type in sense so for the the dual lift
Hill which is very much inspired by the
the one that you have on wallaby
belgium's my train I decided to put a
similar roof over it as well just
because that's also one of the only
parts of the ride where I can really put
a roof over it it's a it's a nice
scenery aspect and maybe it helps in the
rain as well I don't know I'm not quite
sure I always feel like lift hills are
the only part of a ride where I mind
rain otherwise I feel like right rain is
pretty much fine I don't know that's a
weird little tidbit I just remember that
you know being on the lift Hill rain is
really annoying and being on a final
brake run before you get into the
station if that doesn't have a roof over
it the rain is super annoying but during
the right there the ride itself
physically I don't know kind of fun I
should also say that a lot of
rollercoasters will run faster with rain
so while most normal people will
probably not want to have a rainy day
when they're going to the theme park I
know a lot of coaster enthusiasts who
loved to ride coasters in the rain in
any case yeah I decided to add that
cover over the lift hill and now I'm
just doing some of the other theming I
think what's really important when
you're doing is a scenery piece like
this when it's you know featuring a lot
of rock work etc is to have some sort of
transitioning scenery pieces so around
the big rocks I'm putting smaller books
that just sort of scatter into the
landscape and this terraforming to just
kind of help a transition from the rock
work into the sand so it doesn't just
seem like a randomly plopped down mass
of rocks but it also just kind of you
know transitions into the surrounding
area having that sort of I don't know
smooth scenery you know way of placing
it in the context I think is pretty
important now here's the the little
final bits of filling in the theme park
because there are still some empty bits
that I didn't really know what to do
with for this place I decided to put
some tea cups here because that's a flat
ride that I got and it's honestly one of
the only ones that could fit in this
space but also I feel like a lot of the
rides in the park have been getting
pretty intense and it's always good to
have a basic array of family rides so
yeah teacups here we go and then here's
the transfer track which isn't quite you
know the the most realistic
I literally just put an S band of a
different coaster there and ideally you
know in a perfect world in a world in
which this game had transfer tracks
actually maybe this game is better off
without functional ones because it's
really complicated but in any case
ideally that little track would be like
a switch track and not like not like a
real one where you know you go over the
same rails but one where it moves a
little bit so it goes from a straight
piece to that sort of as bends
transition piece these two sort of
shuffle around but you know since we
don't have that I just put in an S bend
there and then the building itself is
pretty simple and here is more of that
sort of transitioning which I was
talking about just putting some cacti
and little rocks everywhere to blend
everything together that's a lot of this
sort of infill is the ferris wheel which
you know if you have a body of water I
don't know for me personally I I can
never not spit the ferris wheel next to
water sometimes it's the end of a Main
Street or something like that that also
works but if you've got like a little
lake or a pond or something I can't stop
myself from putting a ferris wheel there
we'll see if I can control my urges at
some future episodes but for now I'm
gonna keep Ferris wheel in because I
think it works pretty well it's also one
of the only rides which could really
fits into that little space so that
works pretty well and over here I
figured you know this is a pretty
you know sort of far away from the
entrance part of the park and the food
court is right at the entrance because
that's sort of what you get from the
game itself from the scenario itself so
if we pour over here and they're hungry
they don't really have anything to go to
so I decided to put a extra food court
over here and well that's that's
basically it it's a really small one
it's mostly just functional and I
decided to put a very quick depot behind
it but it's super simple you know I'm
almost trying to hide it it's just there
for food and to fill in the space which
is open over here but it's really not
too much of a special building at this
point I wanted to start finishing the
scenario because it's it's already 6:00
in the evening and I still haven't made
dinner yet and yeah what what am i doing
still recording this but yeah I I also
didn't want to finish the park off too
quickly and just have some empty bits
lying around which could be improved so
I wanted to keep going until it was all
filled in and over here I'm trying to
fix the scenery ratings because not
every part of the path is green so
adding some more scenery here and there
and hiding the backstage areas is
something good to do at the end of the
scenario as well I think and as a very
very very final thing I'm actually
before the hammer removing some of the
trees because I was thinking there were
too many trees for a Western scenario
gonna make it a little bit more empty
but yeah as a final thing I decided to
add a toilet building over here because
that's I mean there's one next to the
entrance of the park and there is
another one in the other food courts but
I needed to finish the main street and
put a final building in and since this
part of the Main Street isn't really
connected to those any facades to those
other facades I mean and I felt like I
didn't want to make it a completely
symmetrical disney-style Main Street
because this just isn't quite the park
for that I decided to make it a just a
small Hut's so you sort of finish off
the look of the town and I think it
works alright for that so yeah
let's go and see what the park looks
like in its final form ok this is epic I
think it's actually my favorite part of
this series so far
definitely the best when it comes to
rollercoasters and I have to be honest
making rollercoasters is still my
favorite part of the game
never mind the okay yeah never mind the
stores which still needs some supply
they'll get that eventually but overall
I am really happy with how it turned out
definitely a pretty natural sort of
flowing layouts but with a pretty good
Main Street I suppose in the middle of
the park really happy with some of the
layouts for the coasters especially the
Mine Train and the monorail coaster well
Mouse's are pretty much always the same
anyway so that doesn't really matter too
much and I should be getting the manual
pretty soon should be getting some
confetti there we go all right so we've
completed all of the goals we didn't do
it by December year too frankly we're in
your six already God but yeah that's
awesome so I am definitely going to put
some of this stuff as blueprints on the
Steam Workshop reminder that also the
coasters from the first and second
episode of the series are also on my
workshop page and you can find them in
and descriptions of the videos so if you
want to check that out it's definitely
scroll down there and I definitely want
to blueprint this thing it's a pretty
decent layout I think for the coaster
type even if it's sort of very much
built for the park considering the
pathway that goes here and the flat ride
which is over here but even then I think
it's a it's a decent monorail coaster
layouts the wild mouse is pretty
standard but maybe it's worth it for the
e station and the mine train I don't
know that's gonna be a little bit
difficult wait are those things okay no
nevermind that was actually a block
brake issue that's interesting because
it sort of held on to the end of the
list hill going slower and slower
just to make sure that it wasn't on the
same block as this train but because of
that they couldn't be synchronized so
that's a bit of a shame but still the
interaction between the two trains is
really cool so yeah I'm thinking about
putting the Mine Train up but obviously
I can't have it up with
the pond over here as well but even then
with all of the work work and stuff it's
definitely worth putting up on the work
show oh and it's broken I might not have
enough staff or at least not enough
mechanics
yeah just four mechanics I I sort of
have to get used to how much stuff I
have to get more because in my first
scenario is I had way too little stuff
and I still might have not enough so
definitely like one janitor or one
mechanic more should do the trick but so
far the parks are running all rights and
there's no stuff on the ground
well except with a little bit of vomit
over here so I think I'm doing all right
and then over here the little kiddie
coaster which doesn't have a name yet
I'm gonna have to find some decent names
for some of these rides before I put
them up but I'm pretty happy with this
as well it's quite similar to the other
coasters but still looks pretty good I
think so yeah that's it for this park
not too much else to look at anymore I
suppose so
I'm really glad I did I did the scenario
it's actually my favorite scenario to
play so far as well just because it's
such a sandbox it might be a little bit
more difficult than the other scenarios
in terms of the goals that you have
but then the map itself is very much
just a sort of desert sand box where you
can do whenever you want but you can
sort of pick up the theme which the
scenario starts with so yeah that's
quite nice let's save this and quit to
see what else we're gonna get so if I'm
right I should be getting Coral caldera
and be able to play that next time but I
don't know if it's also gonna already
show the next scenario which I don't
have enough coins for yet all right so
we get the trophy that's nice and we get
one coin and that'll be its then I
suppose yeah we just get an extra
pathway to the coral island where we're
gonna do the next scenario so the next
scenario is gonna be coral caldera which
is gonna be one that I made again and
we're gonna have to sell 800 park
tickets and have
overall Park rating of at least 70% all
right so that's not too difficult and
then actually the optional goal is to
have 400 park tickets so that's sort of
an extra I guess some kind of coaster or
new ride or money that you get halfway
during this scenario and then the
optional goal is to complete all of the
non optional goals by December year -
but we all know I'm not gonna make that
I'm actually gonna want to put a lot of
effort into this one because this is
honestly one of my favorite scenarios
which I've made so yeah I'm really gonna
try and put some effort into this map
again
in any case that'll be it for today so
thank you for watching and hopefully
I'll see you guys next episode